é importante o meio do rio de janeiro e
por lá gente sempre começa a falando
quando a gente vai falar em qualquer
lugar de o nosso lugar fala de onde a
gente é então eu mulher negra escritora
moradora do complexo da maré mais
especificamente do da favela nova
holanda
pra quem não tiver chegando no rio
passarela 9 da avenida brasil e sua
filha de dois pretos e é importante
começar dizendo onde a gente é porque
quando a gente vende periferia favela
subúrbio
é importante mostrar esse nosso lugar de
fala que às vezes a nossa maior potência
ea nossa maior carência
pra mim é um pouco mais complexo porque
os meus pais foram nomes durante anos
então a gente morou na zona norte na
zona oeste e na baixada fluminense eu
nasci sou registrada em nova iguaçu na
baixada e mas pra mim foi importante no
momento transformar essa trajetória a
cigana é não na carência mas na minha
maior potência porque os meus pais na
verdade não tinha dinheiro para pagar
aluguel então a gente ficava rodando e
mas quando eu precisei trabalhar nisso
isso foi muito importante e isso era
muito em um conceito que eu queria
trazer pra vocês na verdade vou falar de
vários conselhos de hoje eo primeiro
deles é a boa prática a boa prática nada
mais é do que entender essas memórias
afetivas o dia a dia que a gente vive
os nossos desejos como possíveis para se
criar uma cultura empreendedora uma ação
no território dentro da cultura é
importante porque ela reconhece essas
memórias esse nosso dia a dia com uma
expressão e que pode transformar o que a
gente vive as nossas produções em outras
coisas e aí nesse momento em que entra o
meu trabalho
a agência agência surgiu em 2001
no rio de janeiro a gente começou
trabalhando em seis favelas em seis
núcleos de seis favelas com experiência
do pepê no rio
e é importante dizer que por lá pelo
menos dentro da gente a gente não fala
em favelas pacificadas a gente fala em
favelas com experiência da upp e agência
nada mais é do que uma metodologia um
ambiente de criação que mistura jovens
de favela com artistas ativistas
mediadores poder público universitário e
das universidades federal e estadual
particular para a une do rio de janeiro
é num ambiente de criação para
transformar as idéias desses jovens em
projetos que possam trazer soluções
tanto para os territórios deles quanto
para a própria cidade e para o país e
para o mundo
pra nós é mais importante do que pensar
a cidade é agir diretamente sobre ela na
vida prática e o que a gente queria
comprovar a maior premissa da agência
era que esse jovem de origem popular de
favelas da periferia ele não era carente
ele não era ele não precisava ser
atendido mas ele era potente ele era
criativo ele tinha ideia e essas idéias
podiam trazer soluções para estes
territórios
mas quem é esse jovem
esse jovem é um jovem negro de favela e
voltando a experiência da upp que tentou
trazer mais segurança para a cidade
especialmente por causa da copa do mundo
e agora das olímpíadas ela chegou a
elegê num certo momento ea declarar que
talvez por ela é legível esse jovem como
inimigo no estado
e ela chegou a declarar que talvez fosse
necessário perder uma geração inteira de
jovens para se conseguir a paz na cidade
a gente obviamente não concordava com
isso então a gente queria esse jovem
o jovem em sua maioria dos nossos jovens
a gente tem 51% de negros porque a
pobreza tem cor
mas a gente entende por exemplo que
territórios como a rocinha que a gente
trabalha que tem uma grande
grassam nordestina a pigmentação é menor
ainda mas não deixou de ser jovens de
origem popular e o que a gente queria
atender esses jovens de 15 a 29 anos
negro e misturar na verdade esse jovem
porque as pessoas acham as vezes que a
favela é tudo igual mas não a gente
queria misturar o jovem da área mais
rica da favela com um jovem da área mais
pobre
o jovem que não tinha terminado o ensino
médio com um jovem que já estava dentro
da universidade
o funkeiro roqueiro evangélico não era
adversidade
esse conceito que já é trabalhado teclas
para os movimentos sociais pelos
movimentos da luta de gêneros as lutas
étnicas a gente na verdade queria
trabalhar com o conceito da diferença
porque não existe um jovem favelado
esses jovens eles são múltiplos
eles são diferentes mas como encontrar
esse jovem a nossa uma das maiores
potências da agência é a mobilização
a gente entendeu que pra encontrar esse
jovem que estava fora dessas redes que
às vezes não tinha passado por nenhum
outro projeto que é não tinha um
repertório muito pequeno que estava
totalmente fora de si as redes mesmo até
do próprio território dele não era
possível só colar um cartaz e esperar
esse jovem chegar a gente precisava ir
atrás dele
então a gente montou caravanas nesses
territórios ea gente entendeu também que
não era possível e apenas na escola nas
ondas que já existiam a gente precisava
tá aonde esse jovem que a gente chama de
ordinário que não é aquele jovem
extraordinário que a dança que já canta
que já participou de projeto que já está
na universidade como a gente queria
misturar e chegar neste jovem ordinário
era preciso chegar até onde estava e
esse lugar é na esquina era a praça era
o estudo era um mototáxi ainda tinha um
horário específico porque a praça às
cinco horas da tarde a gente entendeu
que tinha muito mais jovem do que ao
meio-dia e pensar essas estratégias
chegar neste jovem e é importante também
manter a audiência sobre os programas de
domingo daquela briga gugu e faustão que
a gente viveu é segunda feira tinha o
ibope dizendo quem tinha ganho era isso
era manter esse jovem mobilizar e manter
mobilizado durante quatro meses porque
às vezes a gente chega no território
popular com a nossa grande ideia com o
nosso grande projeto que vai mudar o
mundo que vai mudar aqui é a vida
daquele jovem e às vezes o jovem não
está a fim e ele não é obrigado está a
fim
então a gente precisa manter a audiência
durante 12 sábados ea gente conseguiu
pra isso durante esses 12 sábados a
gente trabalhava a gente trabalha em
cada um deles o que a gente chama de
instrumentos porque não dava também para
chegar num cara de 15 anos e falar a
então você tem uma ideia agora vamos
fazer essa idéia virar um projeto e aí
fazer ele criar objetivo justificativa
público alvo ele não tinha idéia do que
era aquilo então a gente transformou
tudo isso que a gente pensa quando vai
criar um projeto em instrumentos e esses
instrumentos para que ele tivesse tomado
decisões não morais mas decisões
estéticas para a criação um outro
conceito importante na agência é o
conceito de copiar e colar porque o mais
importante não é de quem você copia
mas o como você cola e é isso que faz a
diferença então eu trouxe todos os
instrumentos para vocês quiserem copiar
e colar
o primeiro deles é a bússola a bússola
da agência tem quatro pontos
como todas as moções nosso norte é o
desejo do sul
a idéia o leste a forma e oeste o
território
para nós é importante que o desejo seja
o norte
claro que a gente está no hemisfério sul
é porque originalmente a pergunta que
chega neste território nesses jovens
voltando aos programas do google do
faustão da xuxa e do luciano huck é qual
é o seu sonho
a gente não a gente pergunta qual o seu
desejo porque o senhor às vezes a gente
está dormindo não deseja a gente está
acordado o segundo instrumento
inventário ea gente leva referências
aumento esse repertório pra pensar que o
inventário é uma lista que da
visualidade aquilo que a gente tá
pensando que está lá no mundo das idéias
então inventário feito tanto por donas
de casa quando vão fazer uma lista de
compras como por empresas quando uma
pessoa morre e por artistas
o mapa coloca o inventário no tempo e no
espaço
porque é importante que esse jovem ele
estabelece ele visualiza as fronteiras
do próprio território com quem ele tem
que negociar com quem ele tem que se
relacionar para fazer esse projeto
acontecer
o outro instrumento é o abecedário ele é
a hora em que ele precisa expressar esse
projeto é uma das primeiras vezes em que
ele escreve literalmente falando então
por exemplo é nesse momento em que
aparece o público-alvo do tipo jd jovens
ou sede crianças ea gente traz
referências tanto do the lazy quanto do
abc da xuxa
finalmente o avatar é da agência a gente
entendeu que todo o projeto precisa ter
pessoas diferentes trabalhando juntas se
elas forem as mesmas pessoas
um projeto não anda mas mais que isso é
fazer com que esse jovem tendência
porque também originalmente o discurso
que chega é que esse jovem precisa
encontrar sua essência o que você é lá
no fundo fala pra mim não na agência a
gente pergunta ea gente diz que esse
jovem não tem que ser o que ele é
ele tem que ser o que ele não é e ele
tem que poder ser o que quiser e
principalmente o que ele precisa ser em
cada momento tanto da vida quanto do
próprio projeto dele a gente estabeleceu
que todo o projeto precisa ter pelo
menos cinco avatares o primeiro desbravá
por que é o cara que vai na frente
enquanto os parceiros faz reunião não
quer saber de nada taxa qualquer pessoa
que ele encontra ele fala do projeto
dele mesmo que esteja ainda a cabeça
a segunda pessoa o realizador
ele está muito ligado ao desbravador mas
normalmente ele é o cara que tem as
habilidades aquela pessoa sabe fazer
planilha sabe fazer conta
detalhe para organizar é o cara que
escreve
o terceiro é o colaborador
ele é o cara que às vezes não têm uma
habilidade específica mas qualquer coisa
que você precise ele vai resolver é o
cara que a não têm uma extensão não já
se o detento não é pegar já trouxe
tensão já ligou quando eu vejo tatu
ligar o terceiro não menos importantes o
questionador porque tem que ter um cara
que faz as perguntas têm que ter o case
será que isso vai dar certo mesmo hoje
estamos seis meses nisso gente eu acho
que a gente tem que repensar tudo que a
gente fez até agora
às vezes ele é um chato e por último o
feliz feliz é o cara que relaxa o grupo
enquanto está todo mundo brigando ele
faz uma piada ele pede uma pizza
todo o projeto precisa dessa pessoa a
feira de idéias é a hora em que um jovem
vende literalmente suas idéias e suas
habilidades
todo jovem chega com uma ideia para
entrar na agência precisa ter uma idéia
seja ela qual for
e é nesse momento em que eles podem se
juntar a somar ou subtrair e 10 pra
pensar efetivamente um projeto ou às
vezes o cara que não tá acha que sua
idéia não é tão legal assim ele pode
vender sua habilidade seu avatar até que
finalmente acontece a banca a banca não
é encarada como o fim do processo ela na
verdade uma próxima etapa
todo o projeto tem sete minutos para
defender a sua idéia para uma banca de
pessoas totalmente externas a
metodologia ninguém da equipe participa
são parceiros normalmente que já
conhecem alguma forma à agência
é o poder público artistas ativistas
universitários pessoas da cidade pessoas
também que podem trazer novas redes e
são eles que escolhem as melhores ideias
para receber dez mil reais
a gente já teve várias surpresas porque
às vezes o cara que não tem uma boa e
uma boa idéia tão boa assim defende
muito bem fala muito bem faz a banca
chorar e ganha
e aí a gente conseguiu comprovar nossa
premissa a gente já premiou mais de 100
idéias na cidade do rio de janeiro com
10 mil reais pelo menos
e hoje a gente tem 36 projetos em ação
na cidade
dezoito deles estão com a gente numa
rede que a gente chama de rede agências
são projetos que passaram desde o
primeiro ciclo com a gente lá desde 2011
e que chegaram até aqui já receberam
novos apoios
os outros 18 acabaram de começar a sua
execução e porque depois da banca a
gente tem o que a gente chama de
desincumba doura porque a gente entende
que o jovem não precisa encubar o seu
projeto pelo contrário tem que botar pra
fora de 5 bar e aí eu queria apresentar
dois desses projetos pra vocês
o primeiro descolados de collares é
formado por esses três meninos que pula
salsa e fernando espanhol espanhol
porque ele morou na espanha e quando
voltou para o brasil recebeu esse
apelido
o fernando é boy e quando ele voltou pra
favela do fumacê para quem não conhece
lá no rio fica na zona oeste na altura
de bangu e realengo
ele trouxe a idéia de pensar um estúdio
de criação um espaço para se pensar a
dança que não existia naquele território
ele passou pela banca recebeu dez mil
reais outras pessoas foram chegando e
foi aí que eles conheceram em formar um
grupo chamado descolados que é um grupo
de funk que trabalha também movimentos
ea expressão do hip hop na criação
é importante dizer que eles se orgulham
muito de que a primeira equipe
televisão que entrou na favela do fumacê
pra filmar alguma coisa que não fosse
uma chacina em uma operação policial foi
pra filmar eles a esse é o pai do
fernando orgulhoso no dia do evento e em
outro projeto que eu queria apresentar
que agora acabou de passar pelas
incubadoras é inclusive o inclusive é um
projeto que começou a ser pensado pela
miriam ela moradora da rocinha e tem um
irmão que foi diagnosticado com dislexia
ainda na infância e ela ea mãe tiveram
essa questão trabalhar essa questão o
irmão passou por tratamento e ela
percebeu que outras famílias do mesmo
território em família de origem popular
às vezes as crianças não tinham esse
diagnóstico as pessoas nem pensavam nem
sabiam que era dislexia e aí obviamente
criava adultos com muita dificuldade de
leitura e escrita em outro tantas
questões então começou a pensar um
projeto dentro da agência que
trabalhasse isso e a gente trouxe para
ela a questão de se pensar um projeto
nesse tema que não fosse o tradicional a
palestra a conscientização às vezes até
catequética então ela se juntou com
outros jovens
e aí a partir da conexão com uma um
grupo de teatro e dispensaram cinco
esquetes de atrás que são apresentadas
na casa de moradores na sala na laje de
moradores da rocinha e no final das
casas cats falam sobre esse tema e no
final tem uma discussão com os moradores
da casa como os convidados e um
especialista é importante dizer que a
produção cultural é nesses territórios
ela precisa sair do lugar do atendimento
é um lugar muito difícil porque a gente
está acostumado a chegar nesses
territórios achando que o jovem precisa
de tudo que a gente está indo levar tudo
que eles precisam e na verdade não ele
já tem muita coisa e a gente entendeu
também que na
a agência não tem aquela premissa doha
não vamos dar o peixe
vamos ensiná los a pescar não na agência
a gente vai ao supermercado junto com o
jovem comprou peixe cozinha o peixe
junto comigo junto peixe e analisa toda
essa receita
depois de um tempo o jovem já consegue
no mercado sozinho fazer o peixe sozinho
e aí traz o peixe pra gente provar e
comer junto e aí a gente tem que falar
olha acho que salvou um pouco demais ou
tempo inteiro e é assim que a gente
trabalha mesmo depois desses quase seis
anos de agência o que eu mais me
impressionei foi que eu descobri muito
difícil e de uma forma muito difícil foi
que projovem conseguir tudo isso todo
esse processo
e esses quase mil jovens que a gente já
atendeu
primeiramente ele precisa estar vivo
o brasil é o lugar onde se maio onde
mais se mata no mundo
maior até que em zonas de guerra como
iraque irã enfim todas as guerras que a
gente vê na televisão em 2012
56 mil pessoas foram assassinadas no
brasil 30 mil dessas pessoas eram jovens
entre 15 e 29 anos e 77 por cento desses
30 mil eram jovens negros e o que a
gente está fazendo é importante porque
esses jovens precisam ser visíveis
último conceito da agência que eu quero
deixar é que visibilidade é um direito
que dispara outros direitos a isso
obrigada